就是该处于一个可能要结婚了，
但是在犹豫的一个状态，
你说说现在呢，
现在经历一个买不买房的事情，
然后最近的一个矛盾点就是对我们决定买房的话，
他不愿意的就是产权一人一半，
就是我的出资要比他少个几十万，
大概这个，
呃，
你大概说你出多少钱，
他出多少钱，
我大概就是我们俩如果买的话是一笔贷款，
然后呃，
大概要贷八九十万之后他拿90万的现金，
我拿20万的现金，
这样你那是180万的房子，
那人家不愿意按比例愿意一人一半，
那情有可原吧，
对，
就是心里也会不舒服，
就我其实明理上是知道的，
但是我心里就不太舒服，
本来咱们确实是差距挺大，
你要说你差个三万五万的，
五万八万的啊，
你们家好好，
那你这差老几十万的，
人家出90的，
咱们出20，
你上来要求人家登记50%，
人家不愿意也情理之中啊，
也正常，
如果婚后贷房的话，
是不是也是一要按出阶体的一个词念啊，
不下一样，
就是主要看你们怎么登记，
如果你们不写份额，
你们是在结婚之后买了这个房产，
这个房产也登记在你们两个人的名下，
将来假设要分手的话，
是。
要看谁对这个房子的出资，
更多是要看你们结婚的年头的长短，
是要看你们有没有共同生育子女，
是要看你们是谁的过错，
因为什么原因，
是要看当时的房价，
当时的经济状况，
包括你们的收入都得看，
也并不是说就是公分一共头财产也改价，
共同财产和一人一半这两件事情并不是本耗的关系，
我从法律上把它定义为共同财产，
只能说你也有份，
我也有份，
具体你有多少，
我有多少，
你能分多少，
我能分多少，
就是看我刚才讲的那一系列东西，
嗯，
好，
挺好的，
就不是图他的钱，
就是我本来也是从小被电视剧就是删出来什么的，
而且再一个就是如果演赞啊什么的也不会开心的，
就是感觉他对我好吧。
嗯，
我理解你，
呃，
某种程度上想用这样一个一人一半的这样一个登记，
去求证一下你在她心目中到底占多大的分量，
这个其实女人嘛，
都会有这样一个求证的这样一个心理，
那现在你就已经测出来了，
在人家心目中的话，
可能没有这种分量，
并没有高那个程度啊，
并没有高到说他结婚之前就愿意把他的经济上啊，
财政上啊，
这些东西都交到你手里，
或者说跟你去共享的这样一个程度，
因为现在这个社会实话说啊，
像那种上来就说啊，
我给你买房，
写你的名儿，
我把我的存款给你，
我把我的房产证给你，
像这样的人是很少了，
即便是你遇到像这样的人，
你还记得那个玫瑰的故事里面有个方绮文吗？
方喜文，
在你订婚的时候也是愿意啊，
我这房子也给你啊，
存款也给你，
我什么都给你，
到最后不也会变吗？
所以我们作为女人的话，
上来就别期待，
别期待一个男人会在婚前的时候就把他所有的家当，
所有的钱都给我了，
我要有这样的期待，
我们就不会有这样的难过的是在就是现在大家都还挺理性的，
这一个全方面大家都读成子比较公平合理的做法就是你比如说100万的房产，
你出70万，
我出30万，
好，
我们公平起见的话，
就是我占30%，
你占70%，
非样公平，
那还款的话，
我也还30%，
你还70%，
也非常公平，
有很多人就说，
那也结什么婚呢，
对吧，
我就。
大家先把这个大的财产这个东西，
亲兄弟明算账啊，
大的财产亲兄弟明算账算明白，
然后你该要彩礼你就要彩礼嘛，
结婚之前嘛，
对不对？
因为彩礼这个东西是很明确的，
如果你在结婚领证之前，
彩礼就给你了，
你单独存在一张卡里，
他就是你的婚前财产，
到情况下你还不如让他，
你希望他自己单独买房，
他们自己单独买房，
你买房子这个事你别掺和，
装修这事儿你也别掺和，
这样话女方陪嫁格是要陪家电啊什么的，
不恰当，
也还这么清，
女方陪嫁为什么不能陪前呢？
女方陪嫁的话，
没有谁规定说一定是陪家电，
你像现在有很多有钱让他陪什么啊，
女方可以嫁，
他赔婚前的，
比如说店铺，
婚前就全款买的房产，
或者婚前就全款买的车子，
或者是婚前就买好的保单，
大额的保单，
好多人现在都就是经济条件稍微好一点的啊，
像那种，
呃，
那个三线城市四线城市，
好多爸爸妈妈现在就赔这个，
他不不不赔装休钱也不赔，
家电钱他就赔这个，
我家也赔了，
但我妈就说，
他说到时候结婚的时候要赔个冰箱啊，
什么家庭价钱也也要赔，
这没有一定的这必要，
我觉得赔钱给嫁给钱最合适，
你自己想买电让也给啊，
如果咱们打好了，
说这个房子咱们不打人家的主意。
不想让人家这个房子一分钱的利益的话，
那从一开始房子买房子装修家电你就别插手，
你爸妈给你陪嫁的话，
直接就给你钱，
然后婚前存到你的卡里，
然后这个卡结婚之后就你就别往里面存钱了，
就放哪儿存定期也好，
存大额保单也好，
你存大额的那个什么存单也好，
这样都都说这了，
到就是开支不能开支，
那得看你们两个人，
你们两个人存钱不错，
大家都有，
大家都有工资，
大家都有收入的话，
我觉得人和人是相互的，
人家如果说哎给你买了个衣服啊什么的，
你是不是也得给人家买个什么礼物啊，
这这那的人和人不都是相互的吗？
没有一味的付出，
没有谁会辈子一味的就是因为喜欢我们就给我们付出，
如果人和人一定是相互的，
如果你也有收入，
他也有收入是吧？
我觉得这就是家里面的话，
大家都得付出才行，
不能说一味的让谁一个人承担家里面所有的开支，
本来就一个人承担家里面所有的开支了，
那你存下来的钱也是夫妻共同财产，
那你分手的时候也得分了一半，
这差一个人承担财支，
我们俩都有工作的，
就拿工资一起承担开支是吧？
然后之前的钱不动的话，
就算自己的财产，
对想算你空前在上，
不懂，
嗯，
其实他对我挺好的，
我只是那一刻问了那个问题，
让我有点伤心，
所以我这两天一直困扰了很久，
也就是像王菲姐姐你说的只是为了。
认识一下自己，
想加加心里的分量，
就是得到了这个结果，
然我一个电台过，
再想想呢，
嗯，
你换一个也是这样，
你换一个也方样，
因为现在这个社会，
我们女人对于对方的对自己的那种感情的期待值不要太高，
你不要觉得那个男的会一上来对吧，
所有财产都交给你，
所有房产都写里面，
所有车子都写里面，
原因是什么，
因为你都不知道，
你将来是不是跟人家能过到一块去，
你都无法保证你点，
人是会变的，
我们就没有这样的强求，
没有这样的期待，
我不期待这个男人从一开始的时候对我有这么高的这样一个信任，
我期待的是我跟你结婚之后，
我跟你在共同生活的过程当中，
我们用长时间彼此的支持去证明了对吧，
证明了我值得你信任，
我觉得我这个思路才对，
就刚开始的时候，
不要寄望于人家上来就这么信任感，
因为你自己都搞不好，
就不知道你能不能跟人家过到老，
要通过长时间的那种生活才行，
对吧，
困扰困扰过我啊，
你就开是别他觉得都该问这个问题，
不能晚上，
感情也是一个成长的过程，
你早一天看清这个真相，
你早一天免疫，
你别等到是吧，
到时候怀着孕啊，
大着肚子再问这方面的问题的时候，
你其实更伤心，
我觉得有的时候举个例子吧，
说以后假设我有一个闺女的话，
她想要谈恋爱了，
甭管她十几岁，
她想要谈恋爱的话，
我就谈吧，
你早。
变伤心早一天的免疫，
早一天知道别人有可能没那么喜欢我，
早一天知道别人有可能甩了我，
早一天知道别人有可能拒绝我，
你早一天能免疫啊，
就像你就现在问了这个问题，
现在伤心还免疫了，
别等到你最脆弱的时候再去免疫这些东西，
但这个问题是他父亲提出来的，
他父亲嗯，
首先提出来说要按比例来这或者是他全款买车，
我他开始几乎铺的话也没有多想，
我就说再不如让我们家买一个更好的房子，
那单其实让他们家全款买，
登记在他一个人名下，
就态度很明确，
这个房子跟我一分钱关系也没有，
我也不会惦记，
好，
那也可以，
嗯，
好吧，
那就谢这样，
谢谢，
嗯嗯嗯，
好拜。